[Musik und Tippgeräusche]
[Murat haut auf den Tisch]
MURAT: Also Leute, die Hütte brennt.
In einer Woche haben wir eine Hammer Kooperation.
Wir müssen unseren neuen Partner vorstellen.
Da muss... Ich brauche richtig geniale Ideen.
Und die backt da hinten.
Versteht ihr? Sowas richtig Geniales muss durch die Decke gehen.
Wir müssen innerlich selber brennen,
um das Feuer in anderen zu entfachen.
Sarah!
SARAH: [Mit vollem Mund] Was? Was ist?
VOLKAN: Let's shoot a Netflix video.
[Akustik-Soundtrack von "Haus des Geldes"]
[Faltgeräusche von Volkan]
Questa mattina
mi sono alzato
o bella, ciao! bella, ciao! bella, ciao, ciao, ciao!
Questa mattina
mi sono alzato
ed ho trovato l'invasor.
O partigiano,
portami via,
o bella, ciao! bella, ciao! bella...
VOLKAN: Neckarsulm an Waghäusel.
Sind Sie gelandet?
MURAT: Neckarsulm, Waghäusel ist gelandet.
VOLKAN: [Mit englischem Akzent] Holen Sie mir die Rezepte heraus.
I count on you.
MURAT: Roger, Neckarsulm.
Was heißt "I count of you"?
GÜNI: Ich zähl auf dich.
MURAT: Danke, Darmstadt.
Bad Wimpfen,
Nordrhein-Westfalen,
wir gehen rein und holen uns die Rezepte.
Wenn unterwegs etwas passiert,
lassen wir die Person liegen. Die Mission zählt!
Haben wir uns verstanden?
ALLE: Ja!
MURAT: Seid ihr bereit?
ALLE: Nein!
MURAT: Los!
[Akustik-Soundtrack von "Haus des Geldes"]
partigiano
Tu mi devi seppellir
MURAT: Warte, warte!
[Geräusche der Anstrengung]
Wartet doch! Ihr Idioten! Ne, wartet doch!
Ah!
GÜNI: Sagt mal, wie blöd kann man sein?
MURAT: Darmstadt, wie bist du hier reingekommen?
GÜNI: Das Tor ist offen.
MURAT: Wie blöd kann man sein?
GÜNI: Ja, frag ich mich auch.
SALLY: Murat, echt jetzt?
Rein jetzt, ab!
Hop hop!
MURAT: Oah!
Oh man!
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Eh, wir brauchen irgendetwas anderes.
Wir brauchen eine andere geniale Idee.
VOLKAN: Waghäusel!
Waghäusel, was ist da los? [Actiongeräusche]
Waghäusel!
MURAT: Volkan, eh, eh, eh...
Es hat...
It was not...
Vergiss es, Volkan!
Tschüss!
Wir brauchen 'ne geniale Idee. Es hat nicht funktioniert.
Die Musik war gut.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Hip-Hop Beat]
DENNIS: Yo, das geht raus an die ganzen Penny-Sammler da draußen.
Kein Undercover-Flex,
doch all die andern lagen uns zu Füßen.
Ey digga, was ist jetzt?
Übertreibt die Lage nicht, ihr Süßen.
Unser neuer Bro, bekannt für seine Frische,
setzen neue Standards in der Küche.
Schon seit Jahren die Vielfalt, die Auswahl,
sowas kannste dir nicht ausmal'n.
Hab neue Partner heute, was geht ab Leute?
Straight outta Waghäusel.
Und dieser Lifestyle ist schick.
Sally und die Company einfach nur sick!
[Hip-Hop Beat]
Und dieser Lifestyle ist schick.
Sally und die Company einfach nur sick!
MURAT: Halt! Halt! Halt! Stopp! Stopp, please!
BADI: Sag mal Dennis, weißt du, was das kostet?
MURAT: Was lief schief in deiner Kindheit?
DENNIS: Ey!
MURAT: Das passt doch nicht zu uns!
Wenn das Sally mitkriegt.
Weißt du, was das kostet?
Sorry, Mädels, sorry!
Sorry!
DENNIS: Die sind aus Australien man.
Sorry girls.
MURAT: Digger, bei dir hackt's doch nicht. Also, Wahnsinn!
DENNIS: 5 minutes, okay? We will... discuss.
Eh, aber nur... Wir müssen doch...
MURAT: Nimm deine Lampe, Dennis!
Viel Spaß damit!
Danke!
DENNIS: Elli?
Produkte?
Ehm...
Könnt vielleicht auch gut aussehen. Ich probier's mal, ja?
Okay, eh...
Josh, du filmst noch?
[Räuspert]
Kein Undercover-Flex,
Ach, das ist auch nix.
Dann... Dann lassen wir's lieber gleich bleiben.
[Voiceover von Murat] Hallo?
Hallo? Hallo?
Hört ihr mich? Wir brauchen eine Idee. Hallo?
SIAMAK: Eh, wie wär's mit Influencer?
Sallys Welt hat eine neue Kooperation.
Und zur Feier des Tages gibt es mit dem Code "Yoshi20"
20 % auf alles, außer auf Tiernahrung.
Schaut unbedingt vorbei.
Adiós!
[Influencer-Stimmen]
INFLUENCERFORFREE: Ich grüße euch aus Dubai.
Shoutout an dieser Stelle an meine Freundin Sally nach Waghäusel
NOCHMAL.PAPA: Swiped hoch. Ehm, schaut euch die Sachen an,...
TNATOR16: Hallo, grüßt euch, ihr Lieben.
Schaut mal, was ich hier habe.
Das ist der neue...
SALLY: Ne, das ist auch nicht das Richtige.
Also... [verneint] mm, mm.
SARAH: Sally?
SALLY: Sarah?
SARAH: Denkst du auch, was ich denk?
Ihr wisst Bescheid.
ALLE: [Durcheinander] Oh nein! Oh mein Gott! Nein!
SALLY: Oh doch!
SIAMAK: Also ich find's geil.
MURAT: Was? Dich hat der Teufel geholt!
[Soundtrack "Die Eiskönigin"]
ELSA: Anna?
ANNA: Elsa?
ELSA: Willst du Käsekuchen backen?
ANNA: Wir brauchen Quark und Mehl.
ELSA: Wie sieht die Backabteilung aus?
ANNA: Das ist ein Graus.
ELSA: Ich glaub, ich helf' da aus.
BEIDE: Wenn sie's nicht alleine schaffen,
ELSA: dann bin ich da...
ANNA: ... bist du da...
BEIDE: ... für Menschen groß und klein.
Wir backen Käsekuchen
und laden dazu alle ein.
[Soundtrack "Die Eiskönigin"]
ELSA: Oh, wir brauchen auch noch Eier.
ANNA: Glückliche Hühner müssen's sein.
ELSA: Na los, dann schmeiß den Ofen an!
ANNA: Ich bin schon dran.
SVEN: Oh, die holde Königin und ihre Prinzessin.
MURAT: Raus! Stopp! Ich will nicht aussehen wie ein Schneemann.
Und, eh, Elsa, Anna.
Corinna, Sabrina.
Und außerdem, der Elch...
... der sieht komisch aus. Ich möchte mit nix zu tun haben.
Ich geh raus.
GÜNI: Das lassen wir uns nicht länger gefallen.
SALLY: [Voiceover] Aber Murat, ganz ehrlich:
Wenn ich schon nicht singen und tanzen darf, dann...
dann lassen wir es einfach.
Wir machen das, was am besten zu uns passt.
Ich bin keine Schauspielerin, keine Tänzerin
und auch keine Hip-Hopperin.
Dann machen wir doch das und bleiben so, wie ich bin.
Ich kann kochen und backen, Haushaltstipps geben.
Und das alles möchte ich mit euch teilen.
KUNDE 1: Hi! Ehm, was sollte ich nochmal mitbringen?
KUNDIN 1: Ja... Frisch oder aus dem Tiefkühl?
SALLY: Hallo, kann ich dir was helfen? Suchst du was Bestimmtes?
KUNDIN 2: Ja, ich soll für meine Enkeltochter
eine Geburtstagstorte backen,
hab keine Ahnung, was.
SALLY: Wie wäre es mit einem Schokoboden und einer Vanillecreme?
Im Prinzip könnt ihr beides machen.
Also wenn ihr was kochen wollt,
habt ihr ja da vorne die Gemüseabteilung,
könnt frisches Gemüse nehmen.
Oder wenn ihr sagt
"Wegen dem Nachwuchs haben wir nicht so viel Zeit",
dann könnt ihr auch gern tiefgefrorenes Gemüse nehmen.
Also da braucht ihr auch keine Sorge haben.
Das wird ja alles erntefrisch tiefgefroren,
hat noch alle Nährstoffe und Vitamine.
Und ihr habt ein bisschen Zeit für euch.
Bio-Eier hast du schon.
KUNDIN 2: Ja.
SALLY: Das ist schon einmal perfekt.
Und ich würde sagen, guck mal,
nimm doch einfach den Backkakao für den Teig.
Der ist auch Fairtrade.
Da achte ich immer darauf.
KUNDIN 2: Super.
Ich danke dir recht herzlich.
SALLY: Bitte schön. Viel Spaß beim Backen.
Wenn du magst, dann nimm doch einfach hier die Bio-Zitronen.
Die sind unbehandelt.
Da kannst du die Schale benutzen, z. B. für den Zitronenkuchen,
kannst den Saft auspressen
und am Ende die ausgedrückte Zitrone
noch als Spülmaschinen-Deo benutzen.
KUNDE 1: Mega! Merke ich mir auf jeden Fall.
Danke! Ciao!
Und genau so machen wir es jetzt.
Ab dem 15. März gibt es jede Woche
ein neues Rezept von mir auf Lidl-Kochen.de
Ich werde für euch kochen und backen,
meine Erfahrungen und Tipps mit euch teilen
Und ich würde sagen, wir gestalten gemeinsam die Lidl-Community.
Ich freue mich schon richtig auf euch.
Ich habe übrigens noch einen weiteren Song,
aber ich darf ihn nicht singen.
Der Schneemann, der flippt echt sonst wieder aus.
Bis bald!
GÜNI: Hey Dicker, meinst du, die Leute wissen,
dass es jetzt jede Woche bei Lidl Sallys Rezepte gibt?
MURAT: Na klar! Meinst du, die sind so blöd wie du?
GÜNI: Ach ja?
MURAT: Ja!
GÜNI: Ja?
MURAT: Ja, Güni!
[Musik]
SALLY: Also jetzt ist die Katze aus dem Sack.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Die Überraschung ist verkündet.
MURAT: Und ich hoffe, das Video hat euch wirklich gefallen.
Wir haben uns richtig viel Mühe gegeben.
SALLY: Ja.
Also wir wollten im Prinzip euch mitteilen,
aber ich glaube, jetzt habt ihr es
mittlerweile auch mitbekommen,...
MURAT: Also jetzt hat es wirklich jeder verstanden,
glaube ich. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Auch der Güni.
MURAT: Auch der Güni, ja.
SALLY: ... dass wir eine Partnerschaft mit Lidl haben.
Und wahrscheinlich fragt ihr euch jetzt:
"Ja, wie kam es denn dazu?"
Ihr wisst ja, dass wir die letzten Jahre
- um genau zu sein, es waren die letzten 5 Jahre -
mit Globus eine Partnerschaft hatten.
Das war auch eine sehr freundliche Partnerschaft.
MURAT: Das war richtig cool.
SALLY: Das war auch alles echt gut.
Ich muss auch sagen,
dort hat damals auch alles mit dem Dennis angefangen.
Wir haben da den Dennis kennengelernt,
der mittlerweile bei uns im Team ist.
Und es war einfach eine Partnerschaft auch auf Augenhöhe.
Da gab es einfach alle 2 Wochen ein neues Rezept von mir.
Die Rezeptkarte gab es dann beim Globus.
Im Prinzip kommt man da hin, die Rezepte holen, die Zutaten holen
und im Prinzip alle Rezepte nachkochen und nachbacken
und diese mit der Community teilen.
Der einzige Nachteil, muss ich sagen, war einfach,
dass der Globus relativ beschränkt ist.
MURAT: ... und bei uns hier in der Umgebung.
SALLY: Genau. Der ist praktisch in Süddeutschland eher vertreten.
Viele aus dem Norden, die wussten nicht einmal,
was der Globus war.
Viele haben gedacht Baumarkt.
Es war einfach so,
dass auch schon die Rezeptkarten,
die es ja auch kostenlos dort zu sammeln gab
mit Rezeptordner,
die wurden auch schon teilweise online gehandelt.
Also haben wirklich Zuschauer, die eben das Glück hatten,
neben so einem Globus zu wohnen,
haben sich dann die Karten geholt,
die dann online gestellt und verkauft.
Da habe ich schon immer gesagt: "Eigentlich total unfair!",
denn die Karten kosten nichts.
Die geben wir kostenlos für euch heraus
und das wollte ich natürlich nicht.
Mit der Zeit sind wir eben auch gewachsen und
haben uns eben gedacht,
wir brauchen einen Partner, der eben auch groß genug ist
und vor allem der überall vertreten ist,
sodass wir Rezepte machen können
oder auch einmal Signierstunden oder Events machen können.
Ja, im Prinzip haben wir eigentlich
gar nicht so lange überlegen müssen,
denn für uns war es einfach wichtig,
dass wir einen Partner haben,
der vielleicht auch gar nicht so weit weg von uns ist,
also auch recht in unserer Region ist,
und dann kam einfach die Idee mit dem Lidl, muss ich sagen.
MURAT: Neckarsulm ist von uns ca. eine halbe Stunde.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Denn im Prinzip...
Also wenn man eine Partnerschaft hat,
finde ich es auch immer ganz wichtig,
dass man zum einen auf Augenhöhe ist,
dass man kurze Wege hat,
dass man gut miteinander kommuniziert und
dass das Ganze auch recht freundschaftlich ist.
Und ich finde, dass die Kooperation oder die Partnerschaft
jetzt echt gut ist...
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: ... und dass wir einfach jetzt
einen starken Partner an der Seite haben,
der wirklich auch stark genug ist, überall vertreten ist.
Auch da planen wir in Zukunft die Rezeptkarten zu drucken.
Aber natürlich muss das Ganze jetzt erst einmal anfangen.
Wir haben jetzt die ersten Videos schon gedreht, die Rezeptvideos.
Eigentlich verändert sich für euch gar nichts, außer...
MURAT: ... dass wir ganz nah sind.
SALLY: ... wir ganz nah sind.
MURAT: Überall!
SALLY: Genau.
MURAT: Wie gesagt, überall im ganzen Deutschland
- ist eine deutschlandweite Aktion.
In Österreich, ganz cool, sind wir bei Interspar.
SALLY: Genau.
MURAT: Das ist auch das Coole daran, dass wir halt,
dass nicht immer alles schwarz oder weiß ist,
sondern auch dass zwischendrin etwas ist.
Und das ist eine coole Geschichte.
Ja.
SALLY: Ja.
Jetzt, wie gesagt, haben wir damit gestartet
und wollten euch einfach mit diesem Video
das Ganze verkünden, weil ich gesagte habe:
"Komm, jetzt einfach hier auf die Couch setzen und sagen
'Hey, wir starten jetzt hier eine Kooperation.'
war irgendwie doch nicht so das Wahre."
Deswegen haben wir uns im Team
eben wirklich sehr kurzfristig auch überlegt,
was wir machen wollen.
Dann entstand innerhalb von 4 Tagen die Idee zu diesem großen Spot.
MURAT: Wir haben auch halt gesagt:
"Augenhöhe heißt auch immer,
dass man nicht zu etwas gezwungen wird,
was man eigentlich nicht ist."
Ihr kennt uns ja also.
Meine Frau ist, so blöd sich das auch anhört, kein Influencer
Also wenn jetzt sowas z. B. -
Seit ich dieses Ding benutze,
hat sich mein Leben komplett verändert.
SALLY: Entschuldigung, dein Dubai-Hintergrund fehlt.
MURAT: Swipe up!
SALLY: Dein Dubai-Hintergrund fehlt.
MURAT: Achso, mein Dubai. Ja genau, es sind alle Du...
Ja. So sind wir nicht. Das wisst ihr selber.
So werden wir auch nicht sein.
In Schubladen lässt man sich auch nicht stecken.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Wir möchten einfach so sein, wie wir sind
und deswegen haben wir das Video so gemacht wie wir sind.
SALLY: Ja. Also im Prinzip haben wir auch
den TV-Spot fürs Fernsehen gemacht
und dann an dem gleichen Tag haben wir entschlossen:
"Wir machen für unseren Kanal einen ganz eigenen Spot."
Und eigentlich...
also ganz liebe Grüße gehen auch ans Lidl-Team raus,
denn auch das Lidl-Team hat den Spot gerade eben mit euch
BEIDE: zum ersten Mal gesehen.
MURAT: Keine Abnahme, kein Garnichts
SALLY: Ja, denn die haben gesagt:
MURAT: "Macht, was ihr wollt."
SALLY: "Macht einfach, was ihr wollt.
MURAT: So. Könnte vielleicht auch jetzt Ärger geben.
Ich weiß es nicht. Normalerweise nicht.
SALLY: Ich hoffe, ich kriege keinen Ärger für die Gesangseinlage.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Oder du für deine Netflix-Einlage.
MURAT: Ja. Und wir konnten auch irgendwie für das ganze Team -
jeder konnte sich selbst verwirklichen.
Also, ich weiß von meiner Frau,
ich mag's jetzt nicht so, sie mag's...
SALLY: Darf ich jedes Lidl-Rezept jetzt als Prinzessin drehen?
MURAT: Nein, darfst du nicht!
So. Und du darfst auch nicht mehr singen.
Das war's jetzt. Letztes Mal.
SALLY: Dennis wollte schon immer einmal Rapper werden.
MURAT: Genau. Dennis wollte schon immer Rapper werden.
Der hat dann seine Rap-Einlage gemacht.
[Sally lacht]
MURAT: Der Josh, der wollt schon...
Josh ist ein richtiger Kamera-Künstler.
Der wollte schon immer eine Netflix-Serie drehen.
Irgendwann werden wir das auch machen. Das wissen wir.
SALLY: Mit Sicherheit!
MURAT: Auf diesem Niveau drehen, hat er auch cool gemacht.
Allein die Kamera hat über 100.000 € gekostet,
wo wir gedreht haben.
Die haben wir uns ausleihen müssen, das ganze Equipment.
Unser Wasserhersteller in der Region oder bei uns vor Ort
hat uns den Sprinter zur Verfügung gestellt.
SALLY: Ja. Also es war echt eine richtig coole Produktion
und wirklich sehr kurzfristig.
MURAT: Und ich durfte mal einen Überfall machen.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Der Güni durfte mal ein Rentierkostüm anziehen.
SALLY: Der Güni, der kam wirklich in jeder Szene
MURAT: Der Güni kam in jeder Szene vor.
Der Volkan wollte schon immer
bei "Haus des Geldes" der Professor sein.
Wir sagen auch immer Professor, weil er immer tolle Ideen hat..
[Sally lacht]
... und weil er uns immer rumscheucht.
Ich hab immer Angst, dass er mich feuert.
SALLY: Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht,
machen wir eben diesen Spot
und planen den jetzt hier heute auf 20:15 Uhr.
Ich hoffe, dass er euch... Ich denke, er hat euch sehr überrascht,
denn es ist einfach mal etwas ganz Anderes gewesen,
aber eben doch wir,
weil eigentlich sind wir schon Quatschköpfe.
MURAT: Ja, aber...
SALLY: Ich zeig's nur nicht immer.
MURAT: Aber es soll immer ums Rezept gehen. Und das ist wichtig.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: So wird's bei Lidl auch sein.
SALLY: Genau.
MURAT: Coole Rezepte und ein paar Hintergrund...,
ein bisschen Hintergrundwissen...
SALLY: Kommt das von dir?
MURAT: ... zu dem Produkt. Nein, leider nicht.
SALLY: Ja. Ich habe mir nämlich gedacht,
dass wir einfach jede Woche ein Rezept machen
und dann werde ich im Wechsel mal kochen, mal backen.
Ich meine, vielleicht kommen auch mal zwei Backrezepte
und zwei Kochrezepte.
Das schauen wir dann einfach.
Ihr dürft auch wirklich die Rezepte mitgestalten.
Schreibt mir gerne:
was ihr sehen möchtet, was euch vielleicht noch fehlt.
Ich freue mich auch darauf,
wenn in Zukunft dann die Rezeptkarten erhältlich sind.
Und ich würde sagen, wir zeugen euch jetzt
noch ein bisschen was vom Dreh,...
[Murat stimmt zu]
... was so hinter den Kulissen passiert ist,
denn ich muss sagen, wir haben 3 Tage lang
unser Haus auf den Kopf gestellt,
Sallycon Valley auf den Kopf gestellt,...
MURAT: Hat Spaß gemacht.
SALLY: ... die Lidl-Filiale auf den Kopf gestellt,
die Eremitage in Waghäusel auf den Kopf gestellt
und im Hof ist der Murat ungefähr...
30 Mal ungelogen über die Mauer gefallen.
MURAT: Ja. Kannst du das...
SALLY: Hast du eigentlich blaue Flecken?
MURAT: Nein, ich bin gut gepolstert.
[Sally lacht]
Na, wolltest du jetzt hören, ja?
Du wolltest es hören?
SALLY: Nein, ich sage nichts über dein Gewicht.
MURAT: Hast du dir schon mal überlegt,
warum ich noch nie auf einem Bild bauchfrei war?
Hast du dir das mal überlegt?
SALLY: Weil du da blaue Flecken hast.
MURAT: Genau. Das ist es.
Trotzdem tausend, tausend Dank,
dass ihr euch das Video angeschaut habt.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Und ich hoffe, wir können weiterhin so lustige Dinge machen,
die aber einen auch zum Nachdenken bringen.
SALLY: Ja.
Also schreibt uns einfach mal, wie...
Also schreibt uns einfach euer Feedback.
MURAT: Ja. Ob wir mal so eine richtige Serie drehen sollen.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Also richtig mit Verfolgungsjagd
SALLY: Und wenn ihr Lust habt,
könnt ihr jetzt auch gerne schon
bei Lidl.de vorbeischauen.
Also einfach auf den YouTube-Kanal, Instagram-Account,...
MURAT: ... und abonnieren, dann...
SALLY: ... denn dann...
MURAT: ... verpasst ihr nichts.
SALLY: ... verpasst ihr auch nicht das allererste Video.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Ich freu mich schon.
MURAT: Haut rein.
SALLY: Und jetzt noch einen schönen Abend.
MURAT: Demnächst bin ich bei euch in ganz Deutschland.
Also auch im Haus drin. Ich komme vorbei.
SALLY: Sollen wir von dir auch einen Aufsteller machen?
MURAT: Ja.
Aber ich komme durch die Tür, versprochen!
SALLY: In Lebensgröße?
MURAT: Ja.
War das wieder so ein...
SALLY: Nein!
MURAT: ... Seitenhieb?
SALLY: Nein! Ob von dir ein lebensgroßer Aufsteller bei Lidl...
MURAT: Nein, möchte ich nicht.
SALLY: Okay.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Gut.
MURAT: Tschüss.
SALLY: Tschüss.
[Singend] Willst du Käsekuchen backen?
MURAT: Nein, bitte hör auf Schatz! Sing nicht bitte! Wirklich.
Ich will nicht, dass wir alle Zuschauer verlieren.
Danke.
[Musik]
TEAM: Ruhe bitte!
MURAT: Güni, halt mir das Ding.
[Elsa und Anna lachen]
[Sven lacht]
MURAT: Ich mach das net!
[Alle lachen]
GÜNI: Du machst schön mit.
[Musik]
[Sarah lacht]
MURAT: Benimm dich wie ein Elch!
[Musik]
MURAT: Genau jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
MURAT: [Voiceover] Ich hab vor aus Güni einen Moviestar zu machen.
Aber der Typ kann höchstens eine Wasserleiche spielen -
so aufgedunsen wie er ist.
[Musik]
MURAT: Ah!
GÜNI: Ah!
[Musik]
Das in 3 Tagen zu schaffen, ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Und auch das ganze Team,
werdet ihr jetzt alle sehen, die mitgearbeitet haben:
unser eigenes Team, das Team, wo dazugekommen ist
Wahnsinn! Hat auch richtig Spaß gemacht.
Und es ist einfach unglaublich.
Das Ergebnis seht ihr dann. Wird der Wahnsinn sein.
Das ist wirklich schon auf 'nem Netflix-Niveau.
Gigantisch!
Ja. Echt. Danke nur euch allen!
[Musik]